the local Arabs were preparing to fight  alongside the Allies to defeat the  Ottoman Empire the same British diplomat  secretly plotted to carve up most of the  region between the British and the  French this is the so-called border of  sex people without recognizing and we  will never recognize in a Centurion from  the sykes-picot agreement it's legacy  looks as tortured as ever  na Medusa capillaries crescendo you Zika  dead a poder de seguir see Carrie oh no  L desirable Oh a boat new face in Chile  tomorrow goon preliminar Macrinus a  Cayman deficiency  a study by the amateur International  Boxing Association found that the number  of concussions decreased by 43% when  head guards were removed we're becoming  a bit more likely professionals and I  think it's not the right route we've  taken annually  there are around 800 festivals in the US  alone some industry was nearly ten  billion dollars attracting 32 million  revenues every year  you